even a few days ago it seemed elon
musk's dream of owning twitter was
doomed to fail once again the world's
richest man has shown how dangerous it
is to bet against him in a statement
confirming the takeover musk said free
speech is the bedrock of a functioning
democracy and twitter is the digital
town square where matters vital to the
future of humanity are debated i also
want to make twitter better than ever by
enhancing the product with new features
making the algorithms open source to
increase trust defeating the spam bots
and authenticating all humans twitter
has tremendous potential i look forward
to working with the company and the
community of users to unlock it cargo
dragon take flight but what will a man
who's turned his other pet projects like
tesla and spacex into world beaters due
to a platform that is a voice for
millions i certainly think it's
beginning of a significant new chapter
for twitter and i think that the
platform
has got a lot of problems and this could
be the solution it's been crying out for
but i fear that elon musk will bring um
lots of the controversy that him and his
account um already uh brings with it and
i think that that sort of attention that
sort of those sorts of problems are ones
that twitter could do without and i
think that users and staff at twitter
will probably be uh very frightened
today of what the future holds for the
platform with elon musk in charge
among the questions now will the likes
of donald trump kicked off twitter for
breaching its policies after january the
6th be allowed to return how will
trolling abuse and hate speech be
managed by a private twitter
it'll be a big change too for twitter's
employees in offices like these who now
find they have one of the most mercurial
and unpredictable of bosses and they
like everyone else might ponder what it
means when the richest person on the
planet has control of one of its most
influential of platforms
all that remains open to question elon
musk has promised he will make twitter
better the world wonders what that will
look like